такий заголовок у німецькій газеті ще
донедавна Важко було уявити ми його
заарештуємо так Міністр юстицій
Німеччини Марко бошман в інтерв'ю більт
прокоментував рішення міжнародного
кримінального суду про видачу ордера на
арешт президента Росії на урядових
прес-конференціях в Берліні тема арешту
Путіна цими днями одна з головних
канцлер вже однозначно висловився з
цього приводу він уже говорив що Нікому
не дозволено стояти вище права і закону
це дуже важливий принцип міжнародного
права і всі знають що міжнародний
кримінальний суд Це важлива міжнародна
інстанція місія якої регулюється
міжнародними договорами військові
злочинці повинні відповідати Перед судом
їм не можна дозволити ніде почуватися у
безпеці і це правило поширюються і на
російського президента також
представник МЗС Німеччини не вважають що
ордер на арешт якось вплине на
деескалацію в Україні
ми вже неодноразово зазначали що
дипломатії та спро переговорів не бракує
чого не вистачає то це готовності
президента Росії вивести своє війська з
України та закінчити війну
однак для німецьких фахівців з
міжнародного права Все не так однозначно
юриста нагадують що Росія не має
зобов'язань У рамках кримінального суду
якщо теоретично Путін приїхав би до
Німеччини то Проблема була б у тому що
він як Президент Росії має особистий
імунітет У рамках міжнародного права
і Питання в тому чи не розповсюджується
цей особистий імунітет на випадок коли
Путін розшукується за ордером на арешт
міжнародного кримінального суду
на цих архівних кадрах візит Путіна до
Берліна влітку 2018 року торішня
касларка країни анґела Меркель приймала
його в урядові резиденцію передмісті
берліном судячи з останніх заяв уряду
ФРН це може стати останньою поїздкою
російського лідера до Німеччини реакція
Москви на заяву Міністра юстиції про
готовність заарештувати Путіна була
різко негативною посол Росія у ФРН
Сергій нечаїв заявив що безвідповідальні
заяви деяких німецьких офіційних осіб
про готовність виконати нелегітимна І
абсолютно абсурдно рішення міжнародного
кримінального суду викликають крайні
занепокоєння і свідчать наскільки далекі
вони від реальності у прагнені подальшої
ескалації конфлікту з Росією тим часом
Український президент Володимир
Зеленський назвав рішення про видачу
ордера на арешт Путіна історичним з
якого нарешті почнеться історична
відповідальність в історії міжнародного
права вже були ордери на арешт
главдержав і більшість із фігурантів
рано чи пізно постали Перед судом у газі
Слобода
[музика]
Чарльз Тейлор в історії МКС був один
ордер не виконаний це ордер щодо омара
башира До сих пор он не исполнен і
постали Перед судом кілька главдержав
Хто добровільно з'явився
цей кінійський президент кініато
загалом звісно ситуація така що в
міжнародному суді опиняється колишні
глави держави в міжнародному
суді міжнародний кримінальний суд визнав
що перспективи виконання ордера на
решпутіна мало залежить від самого суду
згідно з римським статутом документом
який підписують країни які визнають
юрисдикцію МКС держава повинна сама
видати підозрюваного газів Росія
Римський статут не ратифікувала та
оголосила що юрисдикцію міжнародного
кримінального суду не визнає нинішнє
фактично перше рішення палати суддів у
справі пов'язані з російською агресією в
Україні ухвалено лише за фактами
незаконної примусової депортації
українських дітей з окупованих Росією
територій
звинувачення полягає в тому що дітей
вивозили літаками поїздами наземним
транспортом у Росію та віддавали на
усиновлення відповідні правові норми
ухвалено указом Президента їх навчали не
українською а російською мовою і вони
ймовірно були прийняті в російських
громадянство це є явне порушенням
четвертої женевської конвенції Але чому
лише через депортацію дітей і чому саме
зараз це свого роду попередження про
злочинність вчинених діянь вважають
експерти
саме з цієї теми розпочав міжнарод
кримінальний суд це якраз дуже зрозуміло
дуже зрозуміло і по-людськи і юридично
ці речі які стосуються питань
незворотних порушень розглядаються
насамперед чому ми говоримо про екстрені
заходи щодо незворотного порушення прав
людини коли йдеться про дітей
вони зростають і вони формуються Це
справді дуже серйозне порушення це
злочин який можна вважати одним із
найтяжчих
тяжких
ордерів поки два один А нарешт Путіна
другий на арешту повноваженої з прав
дитини при президентовійф Марії Львову і
біловою у телеграм-каналі уповноваженої
регулярно з'являлася відео де вона
супроводжує дітей з окупованих територій
до Росії
Ось вона поїздом у квітні 2022 року з
групою дітей
а тут у вересні на літаку разом з нею
125 дітей з Донецької області
30 травня 2022 року Путін підписав указ
який спростив процедуру надання
громадянства дітям з окупованих
територій а також процес їхнього
усиновлення ідеться про підопічних
дитячих будинків дітей які були у
лікарнях чи табурах відпочинку дітей
яких забирали разом із батьками та
розлучали під час так званої фільтрації
наразі повернути в Україну вдалося лише
126 дітей європейські журналісти
розслідували низку фактів примусово
депортацію дітей та поговорили з тими
кого вдалося повернути
фільтраційний табір
Ну там опрашували а потім сказали що
мама фільтрації не пройшла і що мене від
неї забирають даже Вони даже попрощатися
не дали
і приїхали на Азовська служба по ділах
дітей і сказали що вони мене від мами
забирають і потім я ж казав і росіянам
що в мене є бабуся я знаю її номер а
вони казали то ти нікому не надо в тебе
буде нова сім'я Я вірю що її я знайду і
вона приїде сюди Ні я нічого не буду
казати Я обніму її
13-річну Карину доньку Наталії з козачої
лопані забрали Під час окупації прямо з
літнього табору неподалік будинку
ви думаєте Росія хоче залишити у себе
дітей так так
виїжджав ночью вони вже практично делают
всі там паспорти і остаються там сюди їм
як сказали тіпа не разрешають ну я це не
вірю 16 тисяч дітей вивезли до Росії з
окупованих українських територій
стверджують у Києві це офіційні дані на
початок лютого цього року